what is going on here exactly here to
tell us
a man whose name has become a synonym
for wall street's recklessness and
corruption but someone who's actually
learned from his experiences
and has interesting things to say about
the moment we're in right now
he is jordan belford the original wolf
of wall street we're happy to have him
on tonight jordan thanks so much for
coming on the show
so my pleasure you've participated in
this from every possible angle you've
watched it for decades what do you think
is going on here with the reddit guys
well i think you hit it right on the
head and that was my thesis for tonight
was this is really
a convergence of a few different things
number one finally the little guy has
the ability
to fight back through a convergence of
technology the platforms for trading
the ability to communicate as a group so
in the past you could have never done
this before so there are two types of
short sales in this world there's
legitimate ones that's a natural part of
the market and there's another part that
are these
hedge funds that gang up and literally
will short a stock almost
down to zero out of business they try to
spread
negative news they'll start
investigations and that's what
started with game stock massively
overshoring the stock
and this i think as you said connects to
a far bigger thing
than just trying to make a few bucks on
a trade this is about
the end of the movie the or the big
short where like i said all the bad guys
went to jail
ha just kidding no no one went to jail
so i think everyone
knows there's something really wrong in
the pit of their stomach
you can silence people you can
de-platform people
you can um you know um break things with
bleach bit and hammers and get away with
it there's
two everyone knows whether you're on a
republican or democrat there's something
wrong that's why
both sides of the aisle united on this
one thing you notice that
both sides united because it was money
sort of takes the politics out of it
so what happened here is these people
like if you actually
dig into the boards like i did because
my first reaction was ah there's a pump
and dump but no it's really not what's
going on
if you actually look at the messages
these people are mad
they have something they want to prove
it's not really about money they want to
make some money here but they
are angry as hell and they're sick and
tired of getting stomped out by
wall street which they have been forever
and they finally now
have at least some ammunition to get
back the danger is it's going to end
badly for these stocks
and i hope people you know don't lose
money in the process
i wonder though i mean now that this has
happened everybody knows it's happened
and that the hedge funds and wall street
itself are more vulnerable maybe than
anyone imagine and the internet still
exists
i mean what does this portend going
forward how how i mean we can't kind of
continue as we have can we
sure no so one thing wall street and
head
plunge is very good at is closing gaps
and finding these sort of inefficiencies
and closing them up so
what these people already my hats off to
them by the way it was brilliant what
they did
is they found a real inefficiency in the
market and a gap where something
would have been dramatically overshored
and they could actually
you know get enough buying power they
did that wall street now knows that
so i would be very shocked if hedge
funds
would create another situation so
quickly where it was so overly shorted
that it would be that easy for people to
come in as a group and bring the stock
back up and start a short screen so that
might end but
i believe this is a paradigm shift right
now the little guy finally is equipped
information travels instantly now you
see usually only the big guys
they paid the analysts they had you know
all this stuff happened
before the little guy the big guys were
colluding doing this stuff right so now
the little guy finally has the ability
to play that same game at least somewhat
and there is going to be a radical
change it's not going to be the same
so i know you've had an exotic and
famously wild personal life that was so
much more interesting and insightful
than anything i've heard on any other
channel about what we're seeing and i'm
grateful that you came on tonight thank
you
jordan belford good to see you my
pleasure